you do the venture studio thing walk us
through what the economics might be like
is that
a founder comes to you with just an idea
and then you co-founded essentially with
them you're both equal partners or
do you negotiate it every time and then
we'll we'll go on and tackle that uh
signaling issue
sure so um you know it definitely varies
based on
where the company is and its progress um
we definitely have
um co-ownership in certain businesses so
for instance we're working with a
founder
based in australia who has been
developing an app with us for over two
years
we provide um engineering we provide
capital
you know he's providing his skill set
and capital engineering
and we co-own the project so that's a 50
50 ownership but in most cases
when people pitch us projects they're at
some level in their journey
either they're at the very very
beginning or maybe they're already
selling or maybe they're either at scale
and we end up um you know owning a
portion of common shares
that might be at the low double digits
right we almost
you know honestly i can't even think of
the last deal where we had the majority
ownership into anything
we're always going to be low double
digits and part of the understanding is
as they work through that studio
the fund will begin to invest so over
time our position
as common shareholders will get diluted
and basically we work with them on the
capital need and then we typically
deploy
you know million to you know up to 10
million dollars into an individual deal
um so we become very long-term partners
and you know with these founders
how do you make that determination after
you've
done the year of work to get this app up
and running
to then put venture money in or not
because
uh maybe your lp should be like hey are
you gonna say yes to everything and when
you say no to something how do you
decide to say no
and then what happens to that company
does it shut down or does it
go to another firm and then how do they
explain i don't know to
another venture firm they go down the
street to our friend mark suster at
upfront
and he says oh mike why didn't you
invest i guess it's it's not going well
or what's the issue how do you deal with
that signaling issue
that the scouts program had at sequoia
yeah it's happened kind of in three
different ways right so one is that
the company becomes profitable you know
at really really early stages
because they're in commerce or services
and at the end of the day
um it's really not a venture investment
you know they're generating capital
they become break even um it's going to
look more like a lifestyle business and
we don't think you can drive venture
returns
defined for people in the audience who
don't understand the lifestyle business
versus venture returns
what that means to you and in terms of
numbers and practical reality
i mean you know it depends on the market
segment but um
you know we can pick on commerce for a
second so you know
very few commerce companies that we're
involved in whether you're making a
product or a service
um that you know the very few commerce
companies that ex that can't exceed call
it
you know 20 to 50 million dollars in
revenue will ever really be
worth a lot in the market right so if
we're touching a beverage company or a
service business
you know we need to believe it gets to
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue in order to drive
you know a fairly substantial return um
but there's definitely commerce
businesses we've worked with in the
studio
that'll probably be a great 2 million a
year 5 million
a year business that'll support a nice
little founding team you know maybe
they'll throw off a little bit of profit
every year
but the end of the day they're just not
going to hit that next level of scale
whereas in that case it really wouldn't
be appropriate for our venture fund
because the venture fund won't drive the
kind of returns the venture fund would
need got it okay so that's the scenario
one and you said there were three
scenarios so thanks for explaining that
yeah
so scenario two um is really where
either between the
the market i.e the you know the
competitive force of the market
the unit economics of the businesses or
certainly the personality of the
founders
it's just not really going to be a
business that we want to pursue right so
that could be that you know we had a
really interesting business in
you know education technology by the
time they got to market there were so
many competitors
it was clear they weren't going to be
able to break out we didn't think they'd
get to scale
the founders started having challenges
and suddenly for us it didn't look like
a great investment
i would argue it probably wasn't the
right investment for anybody at that
point
now we had already invested some capital
but when it came time for us to really
decide whether we were going to deploy
more capital
it just ended up not being the right
story and in their case other venture
capitalists aligned with our view
not because of us but as they went to
the market no one else you know saw
something that we didn't see everyone
kind of saw the same thing
you know and those founders went off to
go do different startups and sometimes
when that happens they come back to us
right and we do different startups with
them but in that case it was just the
for whatever reason the startup didn't
work out okay so you have number one
it's not going to hit venture scale
number two it's not clearing market
with other investors and it it might
just be
a failed experiment at this point that's
right and that's nobody's fault
and then the third one and that's an
uncomfortable conversation
um but it's not a horrible conversation
because you're saying hey go
get a term sheet and come back to us and
if you can't
well that tells you everything you need
to know that's right well and i mean and
i don't know if you feel this way
jason but in my perspective a lot of
these founders i believe at some point
in their career they actually probably
will be successful
so a lot of time my discussion with them
saying look this business may not be the
right business for you because of all
these other reasons
so the sooner you stop doing this
business and you try another business
you might actually get closer
to that moment of success so in many
cases i'm like look you need to be okay
with us
saying this wasn't the right idea but
immediately let's go try the next thing
and next thing and if you want to try it
with us
i'm super excited because now i know you
and we're excited about building stuff
with you so
i'm really i'm really actually okay if
we do that through a rapid succession
because we save people a lot of money
we save them a lot of time and hopefully
they get closer to whatever is going to
drive their success but founders
are not always that quick to realize it